hello adele and rich paul
hello from the other side
[Music]
following swirling engagement rumors the
superstar singer and sports agent were
spotted cuddling up at the nba all-star
game on sunday at rockin mortgage field
house in cleveland ohio adele looked
chic yet cozy in this leopard statement
coat that she paired with black tights
and knee-high pointed toe black boots
while rich rocked a letterman coat black
turtleneck and jeans yeah no it's been a
complete whirlwind during the game the
couple was seated next to queen of r b
in seoul mary j blige rich was even
spotted chatting it up with nba legend
michael jordan as adele looked on with a
big smile adele and rich's all-star
weekend date comes after the singer made
headlines when she wore a massive
lorraine sword to diamond ring to the
2022 brit awards at the beginning of
february but it's important to note that
adele didn't seem to be wearing the ring
at the game as if i would ever tell
anyone if i was or wasn't
i'm not fluffy though
during her recent appearance on the
graham norton show the songtress
responded to engagement rumors and
revealed she has quite the baby fever
while also discussing how soon she wants
to get her vegas residency up and
running after unexpectedly postponing it
in january
absolutely happening this year okay oh
perfect yes oh very good very good i
want a baby next year
i have plans next year
imagine if i had to cancel shows because
i'm having a baby
now the engagement speculation comes
just months after adele confirmed her
relationship with rich during her
sit-down interview with oprah in
november
and let's not forget many fans think her
latest single oh my god is about her man
[Music]
back in january when the sanctuaries
postponed her las vegas residency show
rumors started swirling that adele's
personal life may have had something to
do with it
hi um
um listen
i'm so sorry but
um
my show ain't ready and
i can't give you what i have right now
um
and i'm gutted i'm guided
but leave it to the rolling in the deep
singer to shut down that idea in a
cheeky way
check out the pics she posted ahead of
her performance at the brit awards in
the caption she seemingly addresses
speculation that her relationship was on
the rocks simply writing quote oh and
rich spends his love
etsy has reached out to adele and rich's
rep for comment on the rumors
[Music]